oh
Six reasons why Smart people can't find happiness
Happiness and intelligent people is the rarest thing I know ernest, Hemmingway
Happiness is the feeling of contentment and satisfaction that is craved by many, but only achieved by some
Happiness is relative and subjective
But for many successful individuals the presence of a great family life in a flourishing career is often not enough
On some occasions [seeds] do not prevent a smart individual from feeling a sense of loneliness
often sadness and Melancholy
Here are strict psychological reasons. Why smart [people] have a harder time finding happiness?
intelligent people overanalyze
many individuals with high levels of intelligence
Often overthink and analyze everything that occurs in their life and surroundings
While their ability to analyze things is a great asset the constant analysis of everything can often lead [to] frustration
especially when coming up with an undesired conclusion
Being able to see through people's intentions is a burden that most people don't get to carry
Oftentimes knowing how ugly the real world is [like] is disappointing and frustrating
Not to mention the timeless dilemmas [of] global and philosophical issues that seem to have no solution is a constant mental [plague] in
This case the same ignorant bliss is true
two intelligent people have high standards
Smart individuals often hold everything with high standards [the] failure to reach these standards often leads to frustration and disappointment
Regardless, if it is their career relationships or anything else that they hold [importance] in their life?
The idealistic view of the world and poor practical intelligence of people with Brilliant theoretical minds
Often have trouble coping with the raw reality of life
When faced with issues that contradict their expectations this inevitably leads to feelings of great disappointment
Three intelligent people are extremely self-critical
unhappiness for highly intelligent people also stems from the deep thinking nature
Not limited to their success and failures these individuals rigorously
Analyze and compare themselves to higher standards that they unintentionally seek reasons to blame themselves
intelligent people often experience flashbacks of events that [happen] months sometimes years ago of
Situations which they believe they behaved poorly or inappropriately
Negative emotions such as guilt and discontent fills their minds and disturbs their mood
Dowsing out any form of happiness of the person
For intelligent people are overly ambitious
People with high intelligence cannot be satisfied with what they already have
Their complex mind gives them the ability [to] see something bigger and better [a] purpose
these people fail to enjoy mundane things in everyday life because their minds crave something stimulating and
Fantastically idealistic that cannot be found in the real world
this is often manifested by inability to accept the time and space they belong to
Do you feel that they are living in the wrong place at the wrong time?
That everything could be better, but it just isn't
[five] intelligent people are often misunderstood
Everyone yearns to be understood and accepted
The comfort of having meaningful conversations with a like-minded person one who shares the same ideas
Worldviews and Philosophies is priceless
Most intelligent people hardly ever find someone who can connect with them
This makes them feel alone and misunderstood that no one is capable of seeing and appreciating the deep brilliance of their minds
While it is scientifically proven that people with high levels of intelligence [don't] need to socialize as much as average intelligence people to be happy
The Human need to interact is still there
people with high intelligence simply prefer to talk